you're gonna share some tips on how to
be more mindful if this is the good in
five all right first something to get
yes
so
do you want to come over here this is
the first thing to get you don't have to
get a lot of things but it's nice to
have um a little meditation cushion or a
little space that you could set up in
your home or your apartment it can just
be like a corner of a room so many of us
are working from home right now
right so it's nice to have a dedicated
space so you can just sit and drop in
just take a couple moments to breathe
connect with your body or do a little
meditation even if it's five minutes but
it's nice because all these decisions
we're always making am i doing it right
where do i go
is this you know the right space you
just have it set up so you can just drop
right in okay something to do
okay so where is the safe place we need
to go into our body right so we want to
have something that we can do with our
body so it's not this big scary thing it
starts with taking deep breaths it
starts with coming into this moment
because so much of our anxiety and
confusion is fear of the future based on
things that happened in the past but if
we come right here right now into this
present moment we can rise up to each
moment so again the mind chatter all the
fears up here in the head right so the
first thing we do is we learn to just
come into your body
and then you just start to take some
deep breaths if you don't have time to
do a full meditation practice because
you know it is a practice it deepens
over time just start by putting one hand
on your heart one hand's on your belly
right so all the confusion everything is
because our peripheral nervous system
our senses are always looking around
here so just by virtue of tuning into
your body you can start to regulate your
own systems and then even one minute or
90 seconds there's research that shows
that 90 seconds is enough to metabolize
a more erratic motion so then we come in
with more clarity these little reset
periods meaning that in the end we
actually save more time because we're
not just cleaning up the mess doing all
these you know the frantic decisions and
running around we just come from this
much more stable calm creative
intelligent place that's inside of all
of us and so i'm going to teach a little
um seated cat cow that you could do at
your desk you can do at any time in the
day and what this does it first of all
it connects you with your breath we're
inhaling and coming like this forward
stretching the heart into into cow and
then exhaling and pulling back so when
everything is just feeling confusing and
there's so much going on you connect to
your physical center your physical
center is your spine right he's so
uptight it's like unbelievable
most
and i haven't i haven't been moving
lately and it's not a good thing
movement is
so important it's like letting yourself
out of the cage that's right and it's
also putting yourself here in this
present moment so we could feel the
bottoms of our feet sometimes we don't
even know where we are birthing is good
take off your shoes and walk on some
nature
okay finally i follow you who is someone
that you follow someone for all of us to
follow what's your suggestion so i think
we all need a safe sanctuary on our
phone right because let's face it
whether you're online at the grocery
store or you're on the train we're going
to go to our phone and so you want to
have a dedicated space for supporting
your mindfulness supporting your inner
connection so we don't want to go
straight to instagram right which is
worlds of chaos for our mental health it
can feel like a lot so i recommend
following the seluna app which is by
yours truly which is all about
like-minded community interconnection
there's free guided meditations i put
out every week that are only about five
to seven minutes so you can carve out
that space there's daily inspiration um
prompts it's all it's all dedicated to
mindfulness and then another thing
that's really powerful love and we'll
stand up for this is just a twist and
again in the middle of the day let's say
your energy is starting to dip or you're
just like in that swirl of the mind
chatter twisting your spine so try to
keep your hips pointed forward in your
feet and you're literally just going to
move from side to side so this is really
great for twisting out your kidneys and
your liver it's like a little energy
boost in the middle of the day and you
feel the power that's inside of you i
feel good for my liver because i don't
drink anymore you know i'm like i gave
that time for a break out just a little
bit of this get the circulation going
and again um this is you want to do all
these movements with deep breaths so
this takes us into this moment where we
can feel that peace that sanctuary the
true self inside of us that's always
there but um what is a good prompt when
we haven't moved our bodies and it's
like
come on get inspired to
twist
and cat cow like what's a good prompt a
good prompt to do it yes so i would say
any time like we so the way that we keep
working our energy is we watch the mind
so anytime you're starting to feel
yourself going into that swirl anytime
you feel tightness inside it could be a
tightening in your belly the flutters oh
like stress is starting to accumulate
tie that to oh let me just break this
for a moment let me do a little twist
i'm glad it doesn't have to be this way
let me shift the energy we have the
power to shift our energy it doesn't
have to be this way
when you feel yourself starting to lock
up
with anxiety stress yes fast crazy brain
i love that
[Music]